[Musique]
avec une casquette et bien non
il est mort
je souhaiterais que vous inquiétiez sur
votre ancien patron qu'est ce qu'on
cherchait
notre ans d'existence d'une troupe la
paire d'heures a été balancé
vous aurez fait ça
bonjour eric rochant bonjour et merci de
nous accorder cet entretien à distance
alors ce premier mois de confinement il
a été très particulier pour vous puisque
vous étiez en salle de montage pour
terminer la nouvelle saison du bureau
des légendes c'est un contexte
particulier puisqu'en même temps les
téléspectateurs trépignaient
d'impatience
de découvrir enfin cette série alors
qu'ils étaient reclus chez eux vous
l'avez vécu comment cette première
période
d'abord avec angoisse parce
qu'effectivement bon angoisse était qu'
on ne puisse pas livré le duo de légende
en fait travaillé 18 mois pour le
derniers mètres de la course se voir
arrêter j'avais vraiment peur qu'on ne
puisse pas livrés et que finalement
voilà qu'il faille repousser la
diffusion
très loin derrière en septembre octobre
donc ça ça c'était très angoissant une
fois qu'on a vu que finalement on
pouvait se débrouiller s'organiser pour
pour terminer quand même à distance tout
ce qu'ils avaient à faire
j'ai été un peu rassurés on a quand même
l'impression d'être un peu dans un film
où le réel a fait plus fort que tout ce
qui a été fait en matière de cinéma /
sur les épidémies je raisonne je réagis
pas je ressens pas les choses comme ça
je me dis pas ronde et comme dans un
film enfin oui on est content j'ai vu
plein de films je les épidémies les yeux
plein de chips ou de catastrophes
naturelles
car en fait on vit une catastrophe
naturelle on perd des gens même très
proche de nous chacun de nous on perd
des gens
pas seulement nos anciens mais aussi
aussi à des gens jeunes l'ingénieur du
son mark and games qui a été avec nous
sur le tournage du bureau de légende
pendant quatre mois cinq mois cet été
alors voilà on était ensemble cet été
en fête a été touché par le crâne à
virus à l'âge de 54 ans d'ailleurs voilà
et donc on a été extrêmement triste ça a
été ça a été un coup de bambou pour tous
les gens qui me connaissent et pour
toute l'équipe mais ça a montré aussi
que voilà qu' il fallait vraiment faire
attention vraiment rester chez soi
qu'est ce que le cinéaste regarde en ce
moment il ya que y'a que de la place
pour l'homme ou déjà vous vous observez
le réel avec un regard d'artiste
alors bizarrement
je sais pas si ces cinéastes qui
regardent pas de vêtements le citoyen ou
d'êtres humains la détente de la planète
je je je je comprends mieux et je pense
que tous les tous les étudiants et tous
les jeunes qui est ce qu'ils vont au
lycée aujourd'hui doivent profiter de
cet instant pour mieux comprendre ce
qu'on leur a raconté sur les événements
sur la guerre l'occupation c'est la
grande catastrophe n'était pas si
naturelle celle là qui a finalement ce
qui s'est abattue sur nos parents et nos
grands parents je pense que la cdc
l'histoire contemporaine évidemment mais
ça nous permet de comprendre un peu les
lignes de force les réactions
la bassesse des uns et la grandeur des
autres ce qu'ils peuvent ceux qui
trouvent la force en e2 voilà moi c'est
ça que je vois en fait c'est une sorte
d'éclairage aujourd'hui parce qu'on le
vit pas au même niveau non plus hein
c'est pas c'est pas la seconde guerre
mondiale mais parce qu'on vit quelque
chose de fort qui nous concerne tous et
qui est assez dangereux et angoissant et
bien je vois un peu des réactions de
chacun et finalement je retrouve des
choses que j'ai vu dans des films sur
l'occupation presque lesquelles par
exemple la traversée de paris par
exemple je pense évidemment à d'autres
où on a vu des gens faire des compromis
trouvé des moyens et en fait on retrouve
à peu près tout les verts tous les
comportements tout et tous les
sentiments qu'on pouvait donc on peut
mieux comprendre en fait ce qui se passe
ce qui s'est passé à l'époque en fait
rien ne change vous avez envie d'en
faire quelque chose c'est trop tôt il
faut il faudra mettre des images des
mots il faudra de la fiction pour
raconter alors qu'il nous est arrivé
aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
auteurs tous les artistes tous les
écrivains et tous les romanciers
écrivent sur la situation qui sont en
train de vie ou sur la situation qui va
qui va arriver je pense que je sais pas
ce que je vais faire car le marché va
être saturé de fiction qui tiennent qui
qui qui qui se passe des histoires
d'amour qui vous savez formidable des
comédies romantiques mais on sent une
pointe de cynisme notre deux voisins qui
sont trop trop de films le confinement à
nous condamner à la médiocrité non parce
que j'ai des poètes et ouest resteront
les poètes ils vont trouver leur poésie
va se nourrir de cette nouvelle
situation qu'est le confinement alors ce
sera aussi sa soit l'enfer c'est les
autres soient des comédies romantiques
il va y avoir un serial killer on va
trouver un serial killer qui commence à
tuer tout le monde dans un building où
tout le monde est confiné ça serait très
intéressant d'ailleurs je te donne
gratuitement l'idée à celui qui voulait
écrire enfin bref en tous les cas il va
y avoir beaucoup de choses en ce qui me
concerne moi
je fais un tout petit peu quand même
hein sorte de pas de cinéma du réel mais
je m'inspire
je place mes histoires dans le réel mais
dans la réalité c'est pour ça que je
fais d'ailleurs le bureau des gens c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait beaucoup mieux
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait des
patriotes j'aime bien raconter des
histoires qui parlent du monde
d'aujourd'hui
qui soit quand même un peu des ombres
divertissante c'est pour ça que je fais
aussi des films d'espionnage c'est une
sorte de faire des films de suspense et
tous en même temps mais donc la
difficulté ça va être alors ces
difficultés et aussi la nécessité savez
d'inscrire nos histoires dans le monde
qui aura connu le corona virus qui aura
connu 7 7
cette épidémie est donc il va falloir
il s'agit pas de faire une anticipation
dans tous les cas il va falloir en tenir
compte alors en tenir compte soit en
plaçant nos histoires dans l'épidémie
pendant les pygmées soit emplacement pas
forcément en racontant l'épidémie elle
même c'est ça je crois pas aujourd'hui
il ya que ça raconte pas grand chose à
raconter d'autres que que dépit des
millions ouais on voit des journaux
d'actualité on parle de absolument rien
d'autre mais quand on va sortir de là
haut quand même qu'on commence
aujourd'hui même moi même à écrire
commencé à écrire et à concevoir des
histoires qui il faudra développer plus
tard on va te ça va être ça va être
inscrit dans ce monde là est ce monde là
on ne sait pas trop bien ce à quoi il
ressemble mais ça va être le monde qui
aura connu ce coronavirus alors vous en
faites pas il y aura des invariants
c'est un peu ce qui peut ne plus nous
rassurer des intermédiaires il y a des
invariants des choses qui vont rester
telle qu'en elle-même et qu'on va
retrouver même peut-être exaspère
exacerbé ou peut-être émoussés et vous
avez aussi beaucoup creuser la question
des hackers dans le bureau des légendes
des états qui surveillent d'autres états
notamment la russie il ya tout un
imaginaire qui ravivait en ce moment
avec ce débat sur le tracking le
tracking sanitaires ou pense à 1984 big
brother on pensa à cette idée peut-être
un peu fantasmé d'un pouvoir totalitaire
là encore n'a encore quelle matière pour
le scénariste ou tous athées
avertissement pour le citoyen tout ça
c'est déjà fait c'est déjà fait dans les
films s'est déjà fait en vrai vous voyez
la chine la chine et leur système de
quota de points sociaux bon c'est
absolument terrifiant ce qui se passe ce
qui était la chine est ce que sera la
chine c'est absolument terrifiant voilà
un dea variante négatif c'est le poids
de la chine et lâchait d'ailleurs y'a
pas la chine dans le gros des légendes
la russie ya l'egypte il ya la syrie il
ya des états unis il faudrait voir la
chine qui va prendre une place qui veut
prendre une place sur la scène mondiale
oui c'est inévitable et si on n'a pas
fait c'est parce qu'on n'a pas eu encore
il fallait il fallait installer les
choses je pense que c'est inévitable que
la que la chine va c'est un peu
l'himalaya qua non là on a monté on a
monté le mont blanc
de montagne comme ça
les malades à qui nous attend qu'est la
chine met
donc c'est ça ça c'est inévitable ce qui
est intéressant ce qui s'est passé quand
même esquisse qui pose une question qui
fera il faudra poser dans des fictions
probablement c'est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le renseignement sanitaires la
question se pose sur
le rôle des rangs du renseignement
aujourd'hui mondiale ne parle pas du
renseignement français et en
anglais
en fait le renseignement sanitaire 30
d'un coup une très grande importance
savoir ce qui se passe en chine n'allait
pas au moment où ça se passe c'est à
dire connaître les chiffres exacts et
connaître la réalité exacte de ce qui se
passe alors même que le détacher loi ne
veux pas qu'on le sache car c'est ça le
renseignement le renseignement c'est
essayer de savoir des choses que les
états ne veulent pas qu'on sache
comme il voudra peut-être au fond des
des espions chinois dans les prochains
numéros parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'
espionnage aussi un
l'espionnage chinois est connu pour être
d'espionnage économique et énormément
c'est à dire le l'espionnage de brevets
de livres des brevets les brevets les
brevets voilà ça c'est important mais je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de structures a
beaucoup d'espions en chine maintenant
ils vont tous être à la porte des
hôpitaux pour voir un peu ce qui s'y
passe ce serait con on termine avec à
nouveau le cinéma qui va pas bien
forcément en temps d'épidémie puisque
des salles ne ne vont pas rouvrir avant
de longs mois et pas simplement en
france le cinéaste il pleure aujourd'hui
alors en fait il est triste
non
non je ne suis pas triste pour elle
évidemment c'est triste tout ça aide
tous les tournages tous les tournages ce
n'est pas une seule personne qui tourne
sauf nous avec petit téléphone et notre
caméra chez soi
ce qui se passe c'est que l'industrie du
cinéma va repartir à bloc et surtout
c'est que ceux qui gagnent de l'argent
aujourd'hui dire il ya des gens qui
adorent j'entendais tout ça beaucoup
perdre d'argent qui gagne et ceux qui
gagnent de l'argent ce sont les
plateformes se sont tous et toute
l'économie de l'abonnement toute
l'économie numérique tous les toute
l'économie de la distance et donc
croyez moi que les plateformes et je
pense que du coup les du coup les
sociétés de production des plateformes
vont avoir beaucoup d'argent à investir
et énormément ça va être massif ils vont
avoir besoin ils ont de l'argent la is a
mass 2 d'argent et donc comme les
tournages sont arrêtés ils vont se
retrouver sans rien et donc il va
falloir alimenter cette industrie là et
donc c'est vrai que je ne suis pas
tellement triste pour en tout cas de
l'industrie de la création
cinématographique car elle va repartir
et elle va repartir plus gros qu'avant
encore une fois je fais le devin et je
peux complètement besoin de me planter
je pense que pour les créateurs non
c'est une pause et encore nous les
scénaristes parce que je suis aussi
scénariste bon ben on a l'habitude
d'être enfermé chez soi pour écrire on
réalise quand même que on écrit bien
enfermé chez soi mais surtout qu'on peut
sortir on sent bien que
création va être stimulée il ya déjà
plein de choses sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya des vidéos il ya des parodies ya
des gens qui ce qui ce film en
s'ennuyant qu'est ce que vous en pensez
que ça c'est c'est stimulant c'est
amusant ou c'est totalement narcissique
les deux je pense qu'il ya de la poésie
partout moi je des gens qui expriment
une très grande poésie dans avec
n'importe quoi avec des émoticônes
j'attends les émoticônes avec les
vasques
j'attends ce qu'ils vont dire qu'ils
vont les inventer mais la création se
niche partout ça c'est mon côté
optimiste là quoi qu'il arrive la
création s'insinue com com comme
l'humidité s'insinue dans n'importe
quelle machine qui serait boulonné à
mort c'est de la chair et du sang ça ça
vient ça rentre dans tout ça moi je la
création ne s'arrêtera jamais et elle
trouve toujours le moyen de s'exprimer
justement par des petits des petites
vidéos il ya des mois je suis pas très
friand de ce genre de choses mais la
turquie joue en une deux qui sont très
drôle et très inventive donc voilà non
mais je fus obtenir pour la création de
jours merci beaucoup c'est passionnant
et revenez nous vite sur sur les écrans
quels qu'ils soient
merci et au revoir
[Musique]